متشكرين تنتقد قرار البنتاغون اسقاطها من
قاضي هواء وتتهم واشنطن بخرق الممارسات
الدوليه
يقر بصعوبه الوضع على الارض
سقف اسعار النفط الروسي يدخل حيز التنفيذ
رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ
الامريكيه اتهموا النظام الايراني
باستغلال القضاء
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره من العربيه البدايه من تداعيات اسقاط
الولايات المتحده للمنطاد الصيني فقد
اعربت بكير عن استيائها الشديد من قرار
البنتاجون ما وصفته باستخدام القوه في
مهاجمه منطادها متهمه لاداره الامريكيه
بالمبالغه في رد الفعل وانتهاك الممارسات
الدوليه بشكل خطير وقالت الخارجيه الصينيه
في بيانها ان بكين ستحتفظ بالحق في اتخاذ
المزيد من الردود الضروريه
وكان رئيس لجنه القوات المسلحه بمجلس
النوابه الامريكيه النائبه الجمهوري مايكا
روجرز عبر عن قلقه من قرار اداره بايدن
سابقا لمنطقه التجسس الصيني بعبور
الولايات المتحده ملتهمه اياها بانها كانت
تامل في اخفاء فشل الامن القومي هذا عن
الكونجرس وشعب الامريكي
واعتبرز انه يجب على البيت الابيض تقديم
اجابات بشان الضرر الذي لحق بالامن القومي
جراء هذا القرار مؤكدا انه يجب على
الولايات المتحده ان تظهر قوتها لردع
الصين وان هذا الفشل مثال اخر على ضعف
اداره بايدن
هكذا انتهت قصه المنطاد الصيني في الاجواء
الامريكيه صاروخ واحد اطلقته طائره اف 22
اسقط المنطاد في المياه الاقليميه
الامريكيه قباله سواحل كارولانا الجنوبيه
وذلك بتوجيه من الرئيس جو بايدن كما اكد
بيان للبنتاجون
يوم الاربعاء عندما اخبرت بموضوع المنطاد
امرت باسقاطه باسرع وقت ممكن وقررنا ان
يتم ذلك من دون الحاق الاذى باي شخص على
الارض وقررنا ان افضل وقت لذلك هو عندما
يصبح فوق المياه على بعد 12 ميلا
انتهاء ازمه المنطاد في الاجواء الامريكيه
لم تضع حدا الانتقاد الجمهوريين لاداره
بايدن على تاخرها باسقاطه حيث اتهمها رئيس
لجنه القوات المسلحه في مجلس النواب
مايكروجرز بانها كانت تامل في اخفاء فشل
الامن القومي عن الكونجرس والشعب الامريكي
الجمهوريون لن يتحكمون في الكونغرس واشخاص
يحشدون للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله لذا
اعتقد ان اي شيء يفعله بايدن او يفعله
الجمهوريون فسيهاجم طرفان بعضهما حطام
المنطاد المتواجد على عمق 47 مترا سيرسل
بعد انتشاله الى مختبر كوانتيكو التابع
للاف بي اي في ولايه فيرجينيا ليتم فحصه
معرفه ما قيمه المعلومات التي صورها
الصينيون
المسؤلون في البندقون شددوا على ان
المنطقه لم يشكل تهديدا استخباراتيا كبيرا
للولايات المتحده لاعتقادهم بان
التكنولوجيا الموجوده فيه اقل تطورا مما
تمتلكه الصين اصلا الحسين الطرد العربيه
واشنطن
[موسيقى]
كيف يعمل منطاد التجسس لمحه ادق تظهر
كيفيه استخدام هذه المعدل القديمه في عالم
التجسس الحديث عندما اكتشفت الولايات
المتحده الهيكل الطائر فوق اراضيها امتنعت
عن اسقاطه معلله ذلك بانه لا يشكل اي
تهديد على سلامه الناس على الارض كونه
يحلق على ارتفاعات تتجاوز حركه مرور
الطيران التجاري والعسكري بكثير
المناطيل عاده تعمل على ارتفاع من 24
كيلومترا الى 37 كيلومترا وفي منطقه تعرف
بجاره الفضاء حيث لا تطير الطائرات
التجاريه ابدا على ارتفاع يزيد عن 12
كيلومترا و500 متر
اما بالنسبه للطائرات المقاتله فهي تحلق
بعلو متوسط بين الارتفاعين حده الاقصى 20
كيلومترا بينما ترتفع الاقمار الاصطناعيه
عاده الى 241 كيلومترا ولدت تحليق في الجو
تستخدم هذه المناطيد مزيجا من التيارات
الهوائيه وجيوب الهواء المضغوط التي يمكن
ان تكون شكلا من اشكال التوجيه ويتم ملء
هيكل المنطاد الرئيسي بغاز الهيليوم او
الهيدروجين وهما اخف من الهواء والذين
يعدان وقودا لمحركي المنطاد ويعاد شحنهما
بواسطه الواح الخلايا الشمسيه مناطيض
التجسس تحتوي ايضا على انظمه الرادار
المحموله جوا ذات القدره على تزويد الطاقم
الارضى بمعلومات استخباريه عن مساحات
شاسعه علاوه على ذلك يحمل منطاد التجسس
كاميرات للرؤيه الليليه والنهاريه وفيما
يتعلق بالبالون الصيني الذي شغل مؤخرا
فحجمه يعادل ثلاث حافلات في حين ان
بالونات الطقس عاده ما يتوسع عرضها الى
نحو سته امتار اذا ماذا يحدث عندما ينهي
المنطاد رحلته اذا لم يتم اسقاطه فسيسقط
تلقائيا في مكان ما
اقر الرئيس الاوكر بان الوضع يتعقد على
الخطوط الاماميه في مواجهه القوات الروسيه
اما المستشار الالماني
فاكد من جانبه ان هناك توافقا مع زلاسيكي
على عدم استخدام الاسلحه المزوده من الغرب
لشنها جبات على الاراضي الروسيه
منظمه الصحه العالميه تقرير يوثق خسائر
اوكرانيا البشريه
الوضع الاوكراني واحد من ثمان حالات طوارئ
صحيه حاده عالميا
اكثر من 14 الف قتيلا ومصاب من المدنيين
و17 مليونا بحاجه لمساعدات انسانيه
سبعه ملايين ونصف المليون لاجئ اوكراني
مشرد في انحاء اوروبا
[موسيقى]
448 هجوما بالاسلحه الثقيله على منشات
الرعايه الصحيه باوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
تقرير منظمه الصحه اشعل مواجهه جديده بين
واشنطن وموسكو
موسكو شككت بدوافع التقرير السياسيه
ووصفته بالمعتمد على روايه الجانب الواحد
فيما دعت واشنطن الى سرعه تحديثه لتوثيق
الحوادث في اوكرانيا منذ سبتمبر
يصادق والاتحاد الاوروبي رسميا على تحديد
سقف للمنتجات النفطيه الروسيه اعتبارا من
اليوم عقوبه جديده تقول اوروبا انها
ستعرقل الاله العسكريه الروسيه في حين
قللت موسكو من تاثيرها على الاقتصاد
الروسي
مئه دولار لبرميل الديزل وخمسه واربعون
للفيول وغيره من المنتجات النفطيه منخفضه
الجوده هذه هي الاسقف التي قرر الاتحاد
الاوروبي فرضها ابتداء من الخامس من
فبراير
على ما تصدره روسيا من مشتقات البترول
الاوروبيون سيسمحون للبلدان غير الاوروبيه
وشركات نقل النفط التي تتعامل مع روسيا
ابرام عقود التامين والتمويل مع مؤسسات
غربيه فقط اذا احترموا السقف المقرر
اوروبيا حسب مراقبين فان الرد الروسي على
العقوبات الاوروبيه سيكون بسيطا لكن صارما
موسكو ستوقف او تحد من تصدير الديزل
لاوروبا التي تغطي نصف حاجياتها من روسيا
وبالتالي ستتعطل مصانعها وستقف الشاحنات
والحافلات لكيلومترات
المحطات الوقود
البدائل المتاحه لاعضاء الكتله الاوروبيه
كلها بعيده وغاليه ومعقده لوجستيا اذا ما
لجات لاستيراد الديزل وغيره من مواد
بتروليه من بلدان كالهند والصين وبالتالي
ستكون الاقتصادات الاوروبيه اذا ما طبق
القرار اول متضرر من العقوبات
اقتصادات ما زالت تعاني من ازمه الغاز
الروسي التي ادت الى رفع تكلفه التدفئه
وانتاج الكهرباء في اوروبا بعد قطع روسيا
الامداداتها من الغاز المسال فستكون
اوروبا حسب متابعين كمن اطلق النار على
رجله مرتين انس نماسي العربيه
تتابعون ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد
الفاصل
مبعوثون دوليون في الخرطوم الاربعاء لدعم
العمليه السياسيه واستئناف المساعدات
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره من العربيه في
واشنطن قال رئيس لجنه مجلس الشيوخ
للعلاقات الخارجيه
استخدم القضاء كسلاح الاسكات الاحتجاجات
دون اي اجراءات قانونيه واجبه
لان الولايات المتحده تفكر في وضع بعض
شركات الصينيه المختصه في تصنيع انظمه
المراقبه والكاميرات في لائحه العقوبات
وذلك بسبب دعمها للنظام الايراني
بتقنيه صينيه يراقب النظام الايراني
مواطنيه وفي بلد يواصل انتفاضه ضد القمع
ترصد كاميرات المراقبه الصينيه المطالبين
بالتغيير نحو مزيد من الحريات دور لبكين
في طهران رفضته الولايات المتحده التي
تدرس فرض عقوبات جديده على شركات المراقبه
الصينيه بسبب زياده مبيعاتها لقوات الامن
الايرانيه باكثر من الضعف عام 2022
وفق الوول ستريت جونل قد تركز العقوبات
على شركه
وهي شركه لتصنيع معدات المراقبه تبيع
منتجاتها الى وحدات الحرس الثوري
ايضا لدوري شركه اخرى تدعى من خلال مشاركه
مدير مبيعاتها في مؤتمر امني نظمته الشرطه
الايرانيه الى جانب لقاءات مع رئيس جهاز
امن الدوله الايرانيه دور الشركات في
ايران قد يعرضها لعقوبات حجبها عن النظام
المالي الامريكي من قبل وزارتي الخزانه
والخارجيه الامريكيه
استخدامات كاميرات المراقبه الصينيه في
ايران يتم بالتعاون بين اجهزه الامن
والتلفزيون الرسمي الايراني من خلال
توظيفها للتعرف على وجوه المتظاهرين ومن
ثم اعتقالهم الى جانب استخدامها في اشارات
المرور لمعاقبه النساء اللائي لا يرتدين
الحجاب وفي ظل محاولات الشركات الصينيه
الالتفاف على العقوبات الامريكيه وانكار
ايران المناقض لتصريحات مسؤوليها باستخدام
كاميرات المراقبه تبقى كل من بكين وطهران
تحت مجهر امريكا والغرب الرافض لسياسات
البلدين
علي السمان العربيه
[تصفيق]
افاضت اعلام الاسرائيليه بسماع ذوي انفجار
في مدينه سديروت شمال قطاع غزه واشاره
المصادر الى تحليق طائرات في المنطقه
بالتزامن مع وقت الانفجار كما نقل عن سكان
في القطاع انهم سمعوا دويا الانفجار بشكل
قوي
اعلن مصدر في امن الدوله اللبنانيه ان
المديريه العامه ستامر بالضبط واحضار طارق
البيطار القاضي الخاص بملف انفجار بارفاي
بيروت مصدر من الامن الدوله صرح لاحدى
وسائل الاعلام اللبنانيه ان البيطار
سيمتثل للامر في حال اصدر المدعي العام
التمييزي مذكره تقتضي بذلك كما قالت صحيفه
نهارا ان اهالي ضحايا انفجار المرفا نظموا
وقفه احتجاجيه شهريه مطالبين باستقاله
القضاه الذين
رهنوا انفسهم لخدمه سلطه سياسيه على حد
تعويرهم
اعلنت قوات الامن التركيه انها اعتقلت 15
شخصا من انصار داعش في اسطنبول وحالتهم
الى السلطات القضائيه وجاء في بين الشرطه
ان الموقوفين كانوا يعتزمون تنفيذه هجمات
ضد القنصليه الغربيه وتحديدا السويديه
والهولنديه واماكن العباده الدينيه
للمواطنين المسيحيين واليهود في تركيا
وذلك على خلفيه حادثه حرق القران التي
وقعت ريستوكهولم
رفضت اعلام سودانيه بان سته مبعوثين
دوليين سيزورون العاصمه الخرطوم يوم
الاربعاء القادم لدعم العمليه السياسيه
وبحر استئناف المساعدات للبلاد وذكر صحيفه
سودا ترابيون ان وصول المبعوثين الدوليين
يتزامنوا مع زياره وزير الخارجيه
الذي سيصل الى الخرطوم ايضا في نفس الوقت
لاجراء محادثات مع مسؤولين في مجلس
السياده والخارجيه
داخليا قال والي جنوب كردفان موسى جبر ان
الاوضاع مبنيه تحسنت بعد اعلان حاله
الطوارئ في الولايه منذ عشره ايام
اصبحت التقارير تجينا من المحليات تؤكد
انه في تحسن كبير جدا عكس ما كان قبل
اعلان حاله الطوارئ
كما اشاره والي جنوب كردفان الى ان زياره
عضو مجلس السياده الفريق شمس الدين كباشي
تركز على الجوارب الامنيه والسياسيه في
الولايه كما ستشهد الزياره مناقشه
التحديات التي تمر بها الولايه الزياره
عندها ملامح ومعالم ومزايا متعدده كانت في
السابق زياره الطابع تنموي خدمي اجتماعي
الان اضفنا لها عاملين اساسيين هما العامل
الامني والعامل السياسي والزياره لها
مدلوله في انها بشكل حراك مجتمعي لكثير
وتضخ
الدماء زي ما بقولوا بالطخ حيويه
للمجتمعات اللي ظلت تنتظر ان جهه مسؤول
رفيعاوى من المركز
لسان حال اهل لقاوه بغرب كردفان الذين
دفعهم تزعزع الامن للنزوح شرقا نحو معسكر
الميناء البري بكادوبلي
ابرز ما يقلقهم غياب ابنائهم عن التعليم
هنا يبحثون عن من يلبي رغباتهم ورغبات
اهلهم في العوده الى الديار عايشين والله
الحمد
لله ما فينا اي شيء الحمد لله لكن الوسيله
بنرجع بس بلدنا نحن من مدينه لنا اربع
شهور
اطفالنا والله كان تعبانين
سيطره عليه استقبلنا عدد 1400 اسره تعالي
لنا 7000
فرد في يوم 13/10 اسره الاحداث القبليه
الاخيره في محليه ويمكن تم تدخلات واضحه
وكبيره جدا جدا من الحكومه الولايه
ومنظمات الدوليه لا يزال الامل رفيق
النازحين هنا فقبل يومين فقط وهب الله
العالم هذه الطفله تهددها امها وتمنيها
لقاء لاقاوه هي وبقيه الصغار في القريب
العاجل
الصعوبات التي يجدها النازحون في معسكر
المينا البري كثيره جدا
ابرزها بحثهم عن الغذاء وكذلك اطفال لا
يجدون مدارس ليتعلموا فيها
مواقف ومناظر انسانيه تستحق الاهتمام سالم
الهاشمي العربيه جنوب كردفان
عرضت رئيسه الوزراء الفرنسيه
حده التعديل المزمع لنظام المعاش التقاعدي
للسماح لبعض الاشخاص الذين بداوا العمل في
سن العشرين والحادي والعشرين بالتقاعد
مبكرا في سن ثلاثه وستين ذلك لكسب دعم
المحافظين للاصلاح في البرلمان واضافت بغن
ان هذه الخطوه ستشمل ما يصل الى 30 الف
شخص
وستكلف ما يصل الى مليار يورو سنويا مما
يعني ضروره ايجاد مصدر للتمويل
بعد اعلان وزير الرياضه البولنديه عن
قياده تحالف من اربعين دوله لمقاطعه دوله
الالعاب الاولمبيه في باريس 20 24 تواجه
كل من روسيا وبيلاروسيا تحديدا جديدا حول
تمثيلهما من عدمه وذلك بسبب الضغوط
المتزايده على اللجنه الاولمبيه الدوليه
والتي سبق وان رفضت معاقبه الرياضيين بسبب
سياسات دونهما
شعله دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه لعام 2024
تطالها رياح تهديدات المقاطعه بينما تسير
فرنسا على قدم وساق في تجهيزات
الاستعدادات للدوره المرتقبه تحول بولندا
قياده حمله مقاطعه لها من خلال تحالف مكون
من اربعين دوله
هدفنا هو ان الروس والبيلاروس لن يكونوا
حاضرين في الالعاب الاولمبيه من خلال
تحالف واسع برئاسه بريطانيا وامريكا لن
يكون للالعاب الاولمبيه اي معنى على
الاطلاق
تصريحات وزير الرياضه البولندي تاتي عقب
اعتراض كل من لاتفيا وليتوانيا واستونيا
على خطه اللجنه الاولمبيه بالسماحل
الرياضيين من روسيا وبيلاروسيا بالمشاركه
في الالعاب المقرره لعام 2004
محاولات اعاده الرياضيين من روسيا
وبيلاروسيا للمشاركه في المنافسات
الرياضيه الدوليه وان كان ذلك تحت رايه
حياديه يطفى الشرعيه على القرارات
السياسيه والدعايه التي تنشرها الدولتان
تحت وطاه السياسه تواجه دوره الالعاب
الاولمبيه في باريس مصيرا غير واضح اما
اللجنه الاولمبيه فتصمم على ابعاد السياسه
عن الملاعب الرياضيه المقاطعه تعد انتهاكا
للمثاق الاولمبي الذي يلزم جميعا لجانب
المشاركه في الاولمبياد وارسال رياضيات
ويشهد التاريخ ان قرارات المقاطعه السابقه
لم تحقق اهدافها السياسيه وكلما فعلته هو
معاقبه الرياضيين
دعوات لابعاد السياسه عن الرياضه يواجهها
تصميم اوكراني على تنفيذ تهديدها
بالمقاطعه بسبب استهداف نحو 300
ملعبا رياضيا في اوكرانيا الى جانب وفاه
220 رياضيا ومدربا وعاملا وفق تصريحات
وزير الرياضه الاوكرانيه
اما امريكا فتواصل دعم موقف اوكرانيا
المصحوب بحملات مقاطعه اوروبيه واسعه
لتبقى دوره الالعاب الاولمبيه المقبله في
باريس على محاكي تصعيد متزايد ومواجهه في
ملاعب السياسه وضغوطها علي السمان العربيه
اجلطت فرق الطوارئ في حدود ولايتي
من منازلهم في نطاق كيلومتر و600 متر من
الحريق الذي تسبب به خروج القطار عن مساره
الجمعه وذلك بعد ان اشتعلت النيران في عدد
المقصورات القطار في بلده فلسطين شمال
غربي
[موسيقى]
في الختام هذا تذكير بابرز ما جاء في هذه
النشره من عرب
اكيد تنتقد قرار البنتاغون اسقاطا من
طائدها وتتهم واشنطن بخرق الممارسات
الدوري
بصعوبه الوضع على الارض واسعار النفط
الروسي يدخل حيز التنفيذ
رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ
الامريكيه يتهموا النظام الايراني
باستغلال القضاء لاسكاه اصوات محتجبه
نهايه هذه النشره شكرا لمتابعتكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]